I love fashion I actually go to bed
every night thinking about what I'm
gonna wear the next day clothing
transforms me defines me gives me
confidence you may not feel the same way
about fashion but I bet you have a
favorite t-shirt or pair of jeans that
transforms you makes you feel good makes
you feel confident makes you feel like
you when I was younger I wanted to be
Betsey Johnson I thought we were kindred
crazy hair spirits together I did go to
fashion design I worked in the industry
for years and loved it I married I had
three kids but life can be
heartbreakingly ironic my middle child
Oliver was born with a rare form of
muscular dystrophy or MD MD affects his
muscle strength his pulmonary system
distorts his body and makes everyday
life more challenging than most from the
time he could walk which was until about
two and a half he had to wear leg braces
for stability because he wasn't growing
appropriately he had to wear a feeding
tube that was placed on his face he
endured stairs and so did I but my
husband Greg and I told him then no
matter what he was just like everybody
else but everyday tasks for Oliver that
we all take for granted were incredibly
challenging that simple act of dressing
yourself the very thing that I adore was
a nightmare for him his form of md does
not affect his mind his brain is an
a-plus which means he's acutely aware of
his shortcomings this became very
evident when he started school and that
daily act of dressing yourself was a
constant reminder of what he
could and could not do so our solution
was for oliver to wear sweatpants every
day to school to parties on vacations
his uniform for special occasions he
would wear proper pants but many times
because he couldn't manage the button
and zipper I would have to take him to
the men's room which was incredibly
embarrassing for him and the other men
that were in there but then my said oh
please there's nothing I haven't seen
before
for years we muddled through but when
Oliver was in third grade I found out he
was more like me than I ever imagined
Oliver too cared about fashion he came
home from school one day and said very
definitively that he was going to wear
jeans to school like everybody else gets
to wear well I certainly couldn't go to
class with him and take him to the boys
room but there was no way I was telling
my eight-year-old that he couldn't wear
what he wanted to wear so that night I
MacGyver the hell out of his jeans I
remembered when I was pregnant and
unwilling to stop wearing my own
favorite pants even though I was busting
out of them that rubber band trick you
moms remember what I'm talking about
the rubber band through the buttonhole
round the button and back instant
stretch so I've removed the zipper so
that it could pull it up and down on his
own I cut up the side seam of the bottom
of his pants to accommodate for his leg
braces applied velcro hold your ears
everybody peel-and-stick mind you so
that it would close around it when I
showed Oliver my arts and crafts project
he absolutely beamed he went into school
with his head held so high those jeans
transformed him he was able to get
dressed on his own he was able to go the
bathroom on his own those jeans gave him
confidence I didn't realize it at the
time but this was my first foray into
the
world of adaptive clothing adaptive
clothing is defined as clothing designed
for people with disabilities the elderly
and anyone who struggles with dressing
themselves adaptive clothing did exist
but it was missing that mainstream
fashion component
it was very medicinal and very
functional but not stylish and that's a
huge problem because what you wear
matters clothing can affect your mood
your health and your self-esteem now
being a fashion lover
I've known this forever but scientists
actually have a name for it it's called
in close cognition the co-occurrence of
two factors the symbolic meaning of
clothing and the physical experience of
wearing the clothing both of which have
a direct correlation to how you feel
about yourself there's actually
professor in the UK by the name of Karen
Jay pine she wrote a book called mine
what you wear the psychology of fashion
she states in her book that when you put
clothes on you adapt the characteristics
of what you're wearing whether you
realize it or not that's why you feel
like a rock star when you put on those
perfect fitting jeans that's why you
feel invincible when you put on that
power suit and that's why you feel
beautiful in that little black dress but
that's exactly why Oliver felt so
isolated when he couldn't wear what he
wanted to wear he even said to me one
time mom wearing sweatpants everyday
makes me feel like I'm dressing disabled
there are 1 billion people on our planet
that experience some type of disability
1 billion if 10 percent of that billion
experience clothing challenges that's an
enormous amount of people that may not
be as confident as successful or even as
happy
as they could be the morning after
Oliver left for school where in those
jeans I realized that I could do
something about that and so I did in
2013 I founded an organization called
runway dreams the mission was to educate
the fashion industry that modifications
could be made to mainstream clothing for
this community that has never been
served and it began with an entire year
of research I went to schools I went to
facilities I went to hospitals I
literally chased down people on the
street who were in wheelchairs or if
they had walkers or even if they had a
slight limp I know I must have looked
insane but I knew that if I was really
going to make a difference I had to
truly understand the clothing challenges
of as many different people as I
possibly could I met a young man who was
18 who had cerebral palsy he was going
to Harvard University he said to make
can you imagine I got myself into
Harvard but my dream is to be able to
wear jeans on campus like the other
freshmen will wear I met a little girl
named Gianna who was missing her left
forearm and her hand her mother told me
she could not bear to see her daughter's
difference magnified by a dangling
sleeve so she had every single long
sleeve shirt professionally tailored to
imagine the time and money she spent I
also had the great privilege of spending
time with Eric LeGrand
former Rutgers football player who was
paralyzed during a tackle in 2010 I had
at this point seen some unfathomable
things but this by far was the most
heart-stopping you see Eric is a really
big guy and it took two aides and a
lifting machine to get him dressed i sat
and watched this process for over two
hours when i expressed my shock to eric
he looked at me and said mindy
this is every single day what can I say
I like to look sharp research done I
knew that if I was going to make a
change in the industry I had to use my
background and really figure out how to
make these clothes modified so I took
the information that I gathered over
that past year and I figured out that
there was actually three categories that
were affected across the board the first
foreclosures button snap zippers hook a
knives for a challenge for almost
everybody so I replaced them with a more
manageable technology magnets magnets
made our Harvard freshmen able to wear
jeans on campus because he could dress
himself second adjustability pant length
sleeve length waist bands were a
challenge for so many different shaped
bodies so I added elastic an internal
hemming system this way Gianna could
wear a shirt right off the rack and just
adjust the one sleeves last alternate
ways to get the clothing on and off the
body outside the traditional way of over
your head so I designed a way to go in
arms first this for somebody like Eric
could actually take five steps off his
dressing process and give him back the
gift of time so I went out I bought
clothing right off the rack I sat at my
kitchen table ripped them apart did
prototype after prototype until I felt I
had great modifications and then I was
ready for the big leagues the fashion
industry rather than designing my own
collection I knew if I was really going
to make a difference I had to go
mainstream I believed that I just needed
to educate the industry of the enormity
of this population and the fact that
these were consumers that simply weren't
being considered and I am thrilled to
say that the industry heard me
runway of dreams collaborated with the
most amazing forward-thinking brands on
our planet
who took my vision to market and made
fashion history by launching the first
mainstream adaptive collection and the
rest is yet to come
fashion holds the key to avoid a
lifeline clothing can be transformative
clothing equals confidence so tomorrow
when you are starting your day and
you're thinking about what you're going
to wear I hope you appreciate the
process and think about how what you
chose makes you feel today
Oliver's 13 he wears his adaptive khakis
his magnetic button front shirt feels
like the coolest kid around my boy has
total swagger as I mentioned Oliver's
disease is degenerative which means his
muscles are going to break down over
time this by far is the most devastating
part for me I have to sit on the
sidelines and watch my boy deteriorate
and there's nothing I can do about it
so I am looking up from the things that
I cannot control to the things that I
can because I have no option and so I am
looking up and I'm asking the fashion
industry to look up and now I'm asking
all of you to look up to thank you
[Applause]